hi my name is Markiplier I am the number
one fidget toy reviewer on YouTube why
and how do I know that because this is
my first fidget toy review on YouTube
and therefore I am the best
that's a bold claim to make what grounds
do I have to make such a bold claim
[Music]
ah
this is awful
and this is the worst thing I've ever
this is the worst thing I've ever done
I'm a sham
I'm ashamed
I don't know where I am hey how's it
going sorry I had a little downward
spiral there what grounds do I have to
say that I have ADHD and that does not
qualify me to say such declarative
things I'm also an [ __ ] which does
give me the grounds to make such claims
but given that eye of ADHD that means
that I unlike you never
[Music]
foreign
you have a different experience of life
than I do
I promise at some point I'll talk in
depth about ADHD and my experiences with
it and I may talk about it throughout
this video and therefore when I say I'm
I will at some point that might be today
but I don't know when but I have ADHD I
was diagnosed when I was about 20 years
old I've been taking medication for it
various therapies they originally put me
on Ritalin then I moved over to Adderall
and recently I changed over to astorus
it's not the ass pills don't mention the
ass pills they're not for my ass they're
called a stars with a z
did spelled like that there's no ass in
there
don't ask but I like this newest
medication because it helps out the most
but you know what else helps besides
medication and therapies and different
things you can do in your day-to-day
life to try to optimize uh the flow and
structure of what you do
number one toy review channel in America
that's right I've got a I've got a
bucket full of toys here and a pocket
full of dreams and I'm ready to show you
the unbiased review of these fidget toys
and to tell you which one is going to
provide you with the best sensory
experience of your life Amazon and
eBay's best toy review ever by
Markiplier the number one fidget toy
reviewer in America and YouTube and the
world
am I rolling oh God I hope so freaking
Amazon Basics XLR cable I don't know the
quality of this
um but I do know the quality of these
toys or at least I will know in a few
minutes because I can see into the
future and know that I will know the
answer at some point but I can't see
Into the Now
oh my God cut that out I'm gonna I'm
gonna actually do chapters in this I've
never done chapters in any video ever
but I'll do chapters in this one if you
care about it I don't even know if
they're gonna be I've never done it
before but I'll do it this time I'm
gonna go ahead and get to it okay I hate
videos that like Ramble On for minutes
and long at a time about what they're
going to do in the video and then they
never actually get to the point of what
is happening in the video and they keep
talking about like in this video I'm
going to do this thing and I'm this is
going to happen and you're going to love
it is like if you would have just
stopped talking at any given moment you
could have gotten to the point where the
things are actually happening and we
could see it happening in real time and
say you talking about what's going to
happen then they have to skip forward
because they can see the Peaks and
valleys in the videos and this
definitely ain't one of them so no one's
even gonna see this one because the
peanut Valley is over there not here
laughs
anyway let's get to the First toy
all right
[Music]
Zoom
this is a pin art oh God did I record
this in 4k holy crap I don't think so
all right it's fine
um this is a uh you've probably seen
these there's a clip of a kid getting
scared by this right here but also a
little blurred because it'll get
copyright claimed
um but this is the thing where it's a
bunch of needles and you stick your hand
and or face in them and then it makes
that thing
I will have a metric of scoring these
that will be based on its uh
alleviations of certain symptoms of ADHD
and general satisfaction because that is
kind of also what this what this is
about it's about being satisfying as
opposed to just being
to cure or anything
a little big I like the color color's
good color's good good color what's with
this
oh my God what's with the paper in the
background
sure what that's about
just like instructions they're supposed
to be there well enough okay I'm gonna
put this right here
come up with this right here okay you're
about to see the magic happen
can you even see that there's a
reflection on it
there's a reflection here we go
[Music]
is it me
is that me
you look like me
no it does
all right let's try that again I can do
that better
bye
that's pretty good all right
I'm smiling
I was smiling does it come across God no
it doesn't one more try
[Music]
it's me
me
it's me so there you have it that's the
first toy uh it doesn't really get the
depth of my face
um but at the same time that's pretty uh
cool I would not give it a lot in terms
of portability one of the biggest things
about fidget toys is that they kind of
need to be portable because if you can't
carry it around with you you can't go
around in public doing it so it gets
kind of like a one out of ten for
portability uh but uh fun is uh nine
nine out of ten real good fun uh
depending on your face and how fun your
face is this is gonna work out real good
for you uh continued fun less so
especially in covet era because you
can't exactly share it with your friends
because you're mashing your face in here
you could do your hand but also
everyone's touching it so Hand also bit
of an issue so uh and number one I don't
think a lot of people want to share
their toys with other people you know
unless it's I don't want like one of the
singers you're like hey can I wear your
glasses and you're like well you don't
have my prescription so it's not gonna
work for me
but also this one uh not covered safe
zero out of ten for coveted compliance
this is not safer at home uh and uh you
guys should be very concerned about this
however
pretty cool I guess I'll uh I'll put my
face in here and auction it off if it if
it like accidentally resets in the mail
that's your fault you the buyer beware
[Music]
foreign
can you tell what that is
all right so that's gonna stay right
there
all right first uh pretty good that's
pretty good pretty good pretty good
[Music]
this um
since this is a fidget blanket hold on
okay number one it broke right it broke
right away this popped right off this is
a zipper if you can't see it it's the
zipper this is a baby toy this literally
looks like a baby toy and maybe this
works for you but I'm talking about my
desire to fidget with this thing
um which I don't have that extreme a
desire to fidget at all you can probably
see I'm very well composed and I'm put
together pretty nicely this is a baby
blanket I'm gonna give this like a zero
I would give giving it a one because I'm
sure it appeals to somebody but it also
broke right away so I'm gonna give this
a zero
[Music]
Henry what is it what is it boy Henry
Henry come here come here it's okay good
boy come here hey come here
come here good boy yo come here come
here hop up can you hop up
where's your good girl what do you have
to say to the people at home pet batter
what about all the bodies that we found
in your basement they gave terrible pets
what do you have to say of all the
people that you killed your bones taste
like they suck at petting you have any
remorse chica out
can't believe it no conscience all right
so we have something here like food
[Music]
there's a lot of plastic so uh these are
the uh these are little poppables so
these are things that you have little
bubbles in them and they're supposed to
be like little bubbles like packaging
bubbles that you pop
[Music]
foreign
I'm sure this appeals to somebody but I
really don't get it right I was popping
there I was really trying to get into it
I thought there was something there but
it'd be perfectly honest
um again I don't know why it's shaped
like a Happy Meal it doesn't really make
that much sound it's a very inconvenient
thing to hold because it doesn't even
hold like a drink this seems like a
dog's chew toy as opposed to a toy for
this so bubble popping in general or the
the kind of like little little punt
rubber punch hole things I get that I I
think I get it and I thought that I
would like this a lot more than I do but
I don't like it because the form factor
is very strange so on the on the concept
on a concept level I'll give it a six
out of ten just because I like the
concept this one's execution however is
probably close to a three like the
colors are vibrant and I get that for
some people that's like really cool
um but the way the rubber kind of bleeds
together on the different ones makes me
think of this this is like a Nasty Patty
or something like that and they're kind
of blending together this isn't exactly
doing it for me and and frankly I'm not
sure who this is doing it for uh because
I don't know if you just really like
fast food but uh you gotta really love
fast food and as a guy that really loves
fast food this still doesn't do it for
me my ideal fidget toy is something you
can hold in one hand and this one ain't
exactly it overall if you average the
six and the two that gets a four good
math congratulations four out of ten
this was in the bin I'm assuming this is
a toy these are scissors
it's honestly not bad I think this was
used to open some packages but not bad
uh it's got some one-handed potential
it's not great good sound though you
know what I mean really nice it's got a
good snap to it pretty cool
I'm not opposed to this one this one's
this one ain't bad I mean look look I
know that it it scissors and it's not
really by Design and you know ha goo
funny it's it's scissors in a fidget toy
video but honestly as a as a fidget toy
it's really not that bad so I enjoy it a
lot
um but moving on
the weight on this one's funky no this
is not my medication this isn't a SARS
this isn't what that is this is
apparently
is a weirdly weighted pill bottle so
it's it's like there's a weight inside
that is oblong pill shaped I don't it
does open it's like a weird
it's a weird weighted pill uh I don't
get this one I I don't I don't get this
one I don't get this one a lot like it's
kind of fun in your hand but it doesn't
really twirl and it's more liable to
fall out of your hand and just like
tumble on the ground and then it's weird
because the physics of it is all over
the place and it picks up funny it just
seems aggravating to me and also like I
get that you know some people are
divided on medication for ADHD for me it
works for other people it may not and
some other therapies might be good I
recommend even if you are taking
medication to still do some of the
techniques and tactics for managing ADHD
like breaking tasks into a small of a
unit as possible like if you need to get
an assay done break it up into tasks and
write it down in a list of getting like
50 words and break it up into multiple
things if you need to go do some errands
write every single thing as an
individual list and that way you can
cross off more and more things and then
it's easy if you can break tasks down
into something that only take takes a
couple minutes or even two minutes or
even one minute or even 30 seconds break
it down into whatever small piece you
can and that helps like that's always
helped me with uh with getting things
done and getting as many things as
possible you can always hope to get in
that flow state which is awesome if you
can get there but it's it's not always
possible so when you need to get things
done that are uh like really really
important just remember to write them
down in as small unit as possible
getting the time to actually do those
things or getting the time to actually
write down those things is the
discipline part try to get that done at
the same time every day that way it
becomes a habit trying to get as many
things possible done as a habit is great
but the problem is when you have an
unpredictable lifestyle that's when
things get hard so make your planning
the habit and then your lifestyle can be
more manageable
two
three
um made in China this is magnetic rings
I honestly have no idea about this one
I've never I've never heard of this one
oh whoa
[Music]
oh they're oh they're weird
[Music]
Oh that's oh
[Music]
I'm not moving them together to move
them they just move because of the
changes in the magnetic field of where
they're positioned
that is fun
fun
very cool okay all right this is cool
this is cool as hell oh that's cool you
could give oh
oh that's cool
oh that
well I'm not cool because I have them
I'm cool because my mom said so
thanks Mom I didn't know I didn't expect
anything out of this I don't I don't
expect anything most of these I've heard
of at least I have not heard of this one
um and it's just literally three rings
that are have magnets in them and they
move and roll and then when you put them
on your fingers they kind of just move
on their own that that I think is like
the coolest feature the way they kind of
pull on your fingers like this if you're
just moving them
um I think that I would rather have one
that was big enough to put on my thumb
and then I could kind of like move it
like that uh but there's there's
something that detracts us from being a
really great thing that I would go to
every day number one you have to think
about it a lot and number two like the
way the fields when they get close it
does pull on your fingers so that you
have to like change and adapt control
and do that really fine motor control
and the problem is with fidget toys you
want it to eventually be aimless at
least this is my mentality about it you
want it to be background thing something
you don't have to think about too much
and this requires just a little bit more
brain power than anything else and
number three if we are on number three
we rumor has it we're not is that it can
create noise I don't like noise I don't
like making noise I'm a noisy guy Enough
by itself you should hear me drinking
soup it's very loud and in me in every
other aspect aspect of my life is very
loud but weirdly enough I am conscious
about the noise that I'm making and I
don't like making that much noise I
don't want to make that much noise and I
hate bothering people with my noise
things like this
that's gonna get real Annoying real fast
and I see you dropping these a lot so
I'm gonna give this a seven and a half
because I really like the potential but
I'm trying to save a lot of room for
things that are going to be really good
and you gotta remember seven and a half
is a pretty high rating it may seem low
but that's pretty high because there is
room for improvement but there's still
way above everything else that I rated
very cool I would not do it I like it a
lot as a quick fun thing but I would not
want it to be a fidget toy that I use
all the time this is just a ball on a
string
it's just a string ball on a string
four I don't know what this is it's in a
thing
oh
okay so this is cool this is like an
Infinity cube right so this thing it
basically can go in a lot of different
directions not every different direction
but it will constantly fold in a
different way if you get the pattern I
don't necessarily know the pattern
because I don't play with this a lot I
guess I never have until I touch this so
I wouldn't really know it's kind of cool
and I guess once you get it it would be
pretty cool the problem with it is that
it's not exactly elegant and I don't
know if it's just because I'm not
skilled enough at it yet which might be
the truth it might be that I'm not
skilled enough to know exactly the right
pattern to go about using this to make
it a really fun experience but for me
right now it takes a little too much
thinking a little too much looking at it
and it's really not nearly as delightful
as the magnetic Rings were I love
magnets magnets are great I know how
they work and I won't tell anybody I'll
take that secret to my grave but to be
honest I won't take this with me to my
grave because it just doesn't seem as
appealing I think cool but coolness
isn't enough to be able to get you far
in life trust me I know I'm extremely
cool but look how limited my career has
been
that didn't make any sense because I'm
[ __ ] awesome and I'm the number one
toy cut all this if I got good at this
it would probably get higher but I'm not
enticed to get gooder at this so I'm
Gonna Leave This at a seven that one was
a 7.5 there's a seven
that's a lot more noise when it falls
six and a half seven I'll be seven
that'll be fair some of you probably
have this as your favorite thing seven
for me
this is similar
one I'm not picking that [ __ ] up
is this just a bean
this might just be a bean
come here
oh oh they got faces on them okay that's
pretty cute okay so it's beans that when
you squeeze them they pop up out of
there and they go right back okay all
right that's pretty cool so that's
that's kind of cool I could see this as
being just a little toy you have on your
backpack and every once in a while you
need something it is the action is
fairly satisfying the portability is
nice the one-handedness is cool and the
Delight of seeing these little that
little face I guess it's only in the
middle
the little face pop-up is a nice
surprise
um do I see myself using this repeatedly
all the time no absolutely not I'll give
that a seven as well that gets a seven
that's nice for someone this will be
very special not for me though
[Music]
did you know that they do that I bet you
didn't I bet you didn't know that I bet
you didn't know that some people don't
know that I knew that or you learned
something new if you learned something
new you have to subscribe that's the
rules uh I'm not even gonna rate that
because these are these are straws I
have a whole bunch of them though I'm
kind of curious what they do together
oh
I just got mad at Sour Patch
I just remembered
something about the colors I guess
could have been
but anyway
[Music]
all right I give those a not a score
because I don't really qualify them as
fun toys well I'll give them a two three
five ten what's your answer write in the
comments below what that one should be
now for a classic something you guys
probably know very well
Hey listen you guys know this one very
well it's near and dear to all of our
hearts it kind of started this whole Toy
Craze you know why because I'm looking
at all these fidget toys how can I look
at the fidget toys without looking at
the OG the Mack Daddy of them all the
McDonald's of fidget toys the basic
[ __ ]
the
me
the fidget spinner
let's see and make this really cool in
MLG like it's a 2010 uh Call of Duty
compilation
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
like love it or hate it it is really
nice I don't personally like it if you
are super individual toys you probably
have played with this at some point in
your life it was popular for a reason
just because it is satisfying it is nice
it is cool uh it does have a proclivity
to drop and cause a lot of noise which I
do not like but that's only if you don't
hold on to it it spawns some of my
favorite videos online if you don't know
anime fidget Spinners by Corridor crew
or Corridor Digital you gotta watch that
video but after this one because uh
Don't Run Away what is it Henry
what is it Henry what is it Henry
Henry
uh we got this which is dope as hell
this is a 3D printed
um Event Horizon black hole machine if
you watched Event Horizon you know about
the the the black hole device that
basically uh caused all the problems and
made the the ship go through hell this
is that device
um pretty cool I like it it spins nicely
it's it's very quiet it's in your hand
and honestly like I like this just as
much as a fidget spinner maybe even more
just because it is one-handed and the
fact that it's 3D printed is cool some
people don't like the 3D printed look of
things but I do in fact I like 3D
printers because I just got a 3D printer
uh here's me with my new 3d come with me
I need to show you something
all right so this is my 3D printer here
it's currently printing something
um
Alexian feel free to censor that
but it's very satisfying get in there
close it's a really nice 3D printer it
prints very fast very well the model
that is blurred that you can't see is a
vase right it's a Vaz it was
pre-programmed in this when I got this
it's also not necessarily obscene
because that is not what that is but
YouTube is a little stingy on age
restriction these days so we're going to
censor it however bamboo lab sent me
this it's really amazing I'm not
sponsored by them yet please I am so
desperate for sponsorships uh a gummy
gummy bears who Sour Patch Kids they
abandoned me Takis abandoned me they
never did any market research obviously
because they would know that I am the
Takis guy and I'm the sour patch Channel
still even after all this time if they
wanted to take me back I would put up a
big fight but I would go back but they
haven't yet so bamboo labs one carbon
yeah yeah good in my book give me more
uh it prints really fast god damn that
looks really good
not because of what it is it's just a
really quality
sorry you couldn't hear me I love this
thing can I have like three more what
are you gonna print Forever at once
it's not that I'm going to print for
something at once is that I'm going to
we're going to print four different
things uh I'll we're gonna print a lot
of things I mean how's it going to print
yeah we're gonna print a lot of things
Amy we're going to this is probably a
painful ass to but we're going to print
a lot of things I mean
you're coming with me
okay no arm no foul
hi we got more fun video coming at you
real soon thanks so much for being here
really appreciate you making this part
of the video just wanted to tell you
means a lot that you've stuck with me
over the years
been doing these reviews a very long
time and glad the people still like them
hoping to bring a few more to bring some
Joy back in your life
thanks for being here
anyway
so this one originally uh my eyes my
hair my right in my eyes it's it's that
length where it's just like stabbing me
in the face oh
anyway
uh I have a hat
um so this toy in particular it was I
was gonna use this and demonstrate it
actually Amy got this for me a while ago
uh you remember maybe you don't the
Unison video where it was like will she
spit or will she oh this is that spit or
Boop
um it is not supposed to be this color
after it's been opened has changed into
a color that is unrecognizable okay this
is not the color that it's supposed to
be this is simply what it is okay I
don't know why it says and therefore I
will not be demonstrating this when it
was at its peak I would give it only a
five because it's kind of cool but it's
kind of gross at the same time where
it's just like
and then that's it and you do that a few
times but uh longevity wise this is not
going to last if this is what the puke
looks like after a while so not good not
not not good not what I would call good
I have no idea what this is
very heavy
extremely heavy
this is like whoppingly heavy I have no
idea
the zipper's broken
on it
great
foreign
magnets are cool I like magnets like I
said I know the secrets of magnets
um but this is just magnets I don't know
if that's that great but at the end of
the day it's still pretty cool magnets
automatically get Five Points just for
being magnets these are a cool color
kind of nice and shiny good design but
at the same time they are just magnets
which is very cool don't get me wrong
very fun uh but again
just magnets this is a screw
this is a Thor hammer
ah I see this is a this is mjolnir but
it's a spinner I think I don't know how
that's gonna work
so
[Music]
kind of fun not gonna lie kind of fun I
don't like that
no one mentioned anything about a hat if
you got to the point where you saw the
Hat organically do not answer any
question about the Hat please disavow
any knowledge of the Hat you see a
comment asking about what's with the hat
say what hat I don't remember there
being a hat there's no hat there what
are you talking about make them confused
okay it's fun for the whole family just
like this that's pretty cool I like that
not easy to spin clearly not one-handed
which is a big detractor for me like
it's got to be one hand really like if
it's a fidget toy it has to be
one-handed these magnets get a bonus
point for being one-handed and the fact
that they're cool this is a solid seven
just for being magnets I mean
okay that is pretty cool
that's pretty cool it's like a top but
not a top
Das pretty dope okay that that went
almost instantly right up to one of my
favorites of all time
I'm not gonna lie and I can do it
one-handed
that's pretty cool that's pretty cool
this is the same as that other one it's
just that Cube thing
this is more magnets
does a nine I've never seen
a fidget spinner toy that spun that
clean that fast while still making that
sound that sounds like it's grinding
which is friction which usually stops
things but I guess this is mjolnir and
it just don't matter this is dope
foreign
this is less dope because when you hit
it your fingers hit it and it stops I
don't know if there's something I'm
missing here that it's not supposed to
be like what I'm seeing uh but it it
just came apart
okay
nine
seven
ah six and a half I actually like just
the Rocks better that's a nine
that's crazy cool love that this is a 3D
printed engine
I wouldn't call this a fidget toy this
is just kind of cool it's a
demonstration of what an engine in 3D
printing can do you can make gears and
if you put a few screws in here you got
yourself a working example of what an
engine in is how it works in the piston
and the push-pull bang boom suck blow
yeah it's the technical terms I went to
engineering
Engineers that's still that only just
now stopping I'm on I I've already gone
through a whole different toy that was
still going
foreign okay so this is probably what a
lot of people swear by when they think
of fidget toys it has a bunch of
different surfaces that do a bunch of
different things some are clicky some
spin some are buttons that button
doesn't work I don't like the two of
these don't actually click but maybe
maybe that's by Design
it could be by Design but I don't like
it you got a bowl that looks like it's
just kind of a rollerball or a press
ball no it's pressed it's like a silver
press and then you get these crank
Wheels I can tell you with 100 certainty
this does very little for me
um mostly because I am not the type of
person that needs something like this to
constantly keep fidgeting it is nice but
again number one I don't like noise I
don't like these clicks I like the
tactile feel of them as much as I like
the tactile feel of pretty much anything
but the problem is I just don't like
making noise and this doesn't really
give me any therapeutic benefits so I'm
going to give this a solid score of the
not this particular Cube because I think
this one's under par but I'm rating the
conceptual idea of a perfect version of
this as a seven and a half
um just because I for some reason in
this video started to give arbitrary
numbers and I'm going to stop that
immediately
until I don't
[Music]
got a clue what this is
[Music]
so what this is is basically a spinner
right you pick the ring that fits your
big meaty claw which I apparently need
the biggest size
okay you put it on your big meaty claw
still doesn't quite fit right but
because they didn't anticipate and then
you do that
maybe I'll put on a different finger
it's basically a one-handed fidget
spinner that's less satisfying
six
I am excited
I'm excited I am excited I'm very very
excited about this one
because I haven't seen one of these
since I was a kid
look at that
now this is something in a different
category entirely this is a visually
satisfying thing you don't need to do
anything about it
just look at it and you enjoy watching
the shapes move and swirl in the liquid
this one really appeals to me because it
doesn't need me to do anything all I
need to do is pay attention to it
only when I want to right it's like
watching that 3D printer work that 3D
printer is beautiful because number one
3D printers in general are beautiful but
that one's good because I can watch the
video feed from afar so I can watch it
build but the most important thing is it
combines the visual and sound this one
doesn't have sound though but it's that
visual component of seeing these things
change and move and they're all similar
but all unique every single one of them
is different even look at that look at
what look it was doing it's been that's
what happens sometimes when you pee goes
off to the side oh it's so me
but it's beautiful and it is like an
hourglass right it just feels like the
inevitability of time is slipping solely
away from you and even if the timer
stopped for something else say a channel
that didn't mean that the timer stopped
for you but that doesn't mean that the
timer is not going to stop
someday
and every grain of sand is slowly
running out for all of us and eventually
you won't even see the end when it comes
it'll just be a slow fade or a sudden
stop and then
foreign
anyway that's a fun idea but I love this
thing it's super cool 9 out of ten just
because I think it's great I love it
this one's an elegant one it's not too
long I kind of it really iffy on the
mood of whether I wanted to go for a
very long period of time or very short
period of time but this one's great
because I kind of love the colors a lot
of people try to do ones with different
colors I like that the colors are kind
of similar there's a purple side and a
red side they kind of blend together and
move together it's just a very vibrant I
like it a lot measuring time very fun
this is not a toy this is a portable
bike pump I don't think it's a toy but
maybe
eight now this next thing uh that I'm
going to show you is actually
this is my favorite fidget toy ever this
particular one is not my favorite
because I lost my other one and then I
bought a new one and it was not quite
made right it's a little noisy it's a
little imbalanced but still conceptually
I think this might be the best it's the
epitome of a lot of different factors
here again this one is not my favorite
because it's not a nice color it's but
it like it hasn't let me get the
scissors out of here but it is nice I
know the blur my hand it's not I'm
trying to amp it up the reveal is not
ready for it so without further Ado blur
it again anytime I see it blur it blur
blur blur blur that you can't see it
blur blur blur blur this is my favorite
I think this is the best version of a
fidget toy that I have found and it
personally works the best for me because
not only can I use it whenever I want it
helps me concentrate which is at the end
of the day the purpose of a fidget toy
and for me a man who has ADHD it helps a
lot
this
is the oh no roller I think it's only
made by one brand at this time you could
probably find different versions of it
for probably cheaper than this because
it's a little bit pricey I'd say it's
too pricey for what it is but all things
considered for me it is worth the price
what it is is two simple rods on a on
ball bearings rotating around a fixed uh
plate on the back free Spin spins in
your hand it is like uh those metal
balls that you spin and oscillate in
your hand I forget what the technical
term here's the technical term right
here
that's what they actually are this is
like those it gives that kind of like
hypnotic motion to it you just do the
same Motion in your hand and it's a
slight roll and you could do it as fast
or slow you can listen there's a slight
click in this one
in my other one that wasn't present and
I can see why because there's a little
Gap defect in this one there's a little
space there where it clicks into itself
every once in a while but even so this
is delightful it is really really nice
it's weighted it's got feel to it it's
got heft when you spin it it rolls
smoothly you don't think about it I can
be writing I can pick this up I can
watch TV I can do this I can do a
podcast recording I can do pretty much
anything because it's entirely
one-handed it's so absent minded no
one's thinking about it and and it just
you can carry it wherever you want
because it fits in your pocket it's not
bulby bulbous it's not this thing it's
not gonna like take up space it takes up
no space and what's even better about it
is you can get a mini version if you
have a smaller hand or you just want
something that's not as heavy they make
a junior version of it too rolls exactly
the same and this gives you an idea of
what it's like when it doesn't have that
defect
that's just the sound of it rolling
against my hand because this one is
slightly more textured no clicking no
anything smooth roll really easy
portable use it wherever you get two
different sizes of it no they don't roll
together or at least not as far as I'm
concerned these are the different sizes
for it I am not sponsored by Ono do not
think that
oh no
oh no
oh no
I'm not sponsored but maybe I will be
someday I would gladly take their money
for more videos entirely dedicated to
this thing if you guys want to pay me if
anybody here wants to pay me my rating
changes I am so for sale it does it
doesn't it's not even funny uh bamboo
lab
give
anybody else I will take so much money I
have to this day not been paid once for
any of my review videos not once have I
ever been actually paid for my services
I have done so many reviews and yet no
one is paying me I have actually spent
so much money just to buy [ __ ] for these
no one has given me anything please I am
begging for it I have no Integrity when
it comes to this I will sell out in a
moment a heartbeat please
anyway
that is my video These are the fidget
toys they are very nice this one's my
favorite check out my other videos this
is the end I appreciate everything about
you please give me money not you
watching the companies that are a part
of this that want more services out of
me all right goodbye
oh how could I forget I'm not I'm not
done shut I'm not done
every time I do a review video it's time
for a little bit of a history lesson and
how could any of us forget probably one
of the earliest fidget toys
the slinky
I now know why we've forgotten about it
um but there are some people that are
incredibly good at Slinky they can do
tricks with it they can make it do crazy
things you can get them in different
colors they look like they will chop
your head off and cut your hand to
Ribbons that's what I always thought as
a kid I still kind of worry about it
it's thin metal and you know if it goes
fast enough it'll it'll cut
but it's very nice
there's something very appealing about
it it's a little noisy I don't really
like the noise but some people are
really all about the slinky and
sometimes slinky's all you really need
except when it gets Tangled and then you
can never figure out how to untangle it
I don't care how many videos I've looked
up I cannot figure it out on dangle this
and a curled cord like an old school
telephone cord I can't do that I don't
know how to do that I don't know how any
of that works doesn't make any sense to
me I've tried to twist it my brain can't
wrap my head around it you give me a map
and give me a destination I'll go
anywhere on GPS one time I'll be able to
go there back and forth every single
time without a map ever looking at it
but you give me one of these I can't
figure out that which way is up or down
uh Seven Ten solid ten not joking my
favorite that is all the fidget toys
that I have I will be auctioning this
off maybe I'm not sure it won't stay I
probably will have to cast in resin if I
figure out a way to cast in resin I will
if not then it'll never show up anywhere
I've bought a bunch of other review
videos
and you can check those out uh subscribe
for more if you would like um ring the
bell I think that still helps I talked
to matpat recently and he said he talked
to YouTube before they didn't he said it
was a really weird idea and they did it
anyway so I don't know they must have
some data about it so please ring the
bell
um thank you uh
I'm not sponsored but I wish I was don't